[Music]
all right marco
get ready this is for real
hey there i'm mark ellis and welcome to
an all new episode of rt essentials if
you're anything like me you just can't
get enough of sci-fi the time travel the
robots the spacecrafts the time
traveling robots riding in spacecrafts
like robot and lost in space
really they named the robot it's just
called robot lazy in space more like it
i digress the point is we love science
fiction and nothing pairs better with
science-based cinema than some grade a
action these scenes don't take no crap
off nobody they're out there they can't
be bargained with and they don't feel
pity or remorse or fear they've come
here to kick butt and chew popcorn and
they're all out of popcorn but hopefully
you're not so go ahead and get those
kernels popping scoop forward to the
edge of your seed and throw on your
favorite tinfoil hats these are the most
badass sci-fi action scenes ever the
truck chase terminator 2.
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
up first is the truck chase scene from
james cameron's classic terminator 2
judgement day in t2 john connor is the
target of a shape-shifting t-1000 you
know the liquid metal guy but luckily
he's got another terminator on his team
the revamped t800 that looks remarkably
like arnold schwarzenegger unlike his
character in the first terminator
arnold's t-800 is actually a good guy in
this film sent from the future to
protect connor which brings us to a
chase in which connor flees from the
t-1000 on a small motorcycle and the
t-1000 steals a semi-truck drives it off
a bridge and chases conor through the
concrete flood channels of los angeles
the t-1000 is relentless but the
governator catches up on his motorcycle
rescues connor just seconds before the
t-1000 crashes his truck into an
overpass and it explodes because a
massive explosion was really the only
way to end such an iconic action scene
cameron utilized massive set pieces
pyrotechnics lots of cables and the
latest cgi available to achieve this
sequence for the shot where arnold's
bike flies off a ledge soars through the
air and crashes down on the concrete
large cranes were placed on the opposite
sides of the jump with a wire running
between them and the motorcycle attached
to that wire so it could swing in the
air and land without serious damage the
wires were then removed in post which
makes this shot look incredibly
realistic
[Music]
[Music]
a practical approach was also used for
when the semi truck smashes through a
wall then leaps off the high-rise
freeway and lands in the canal below a
large fake wall was built which also
concealed a ramp that the vehicle
required to gain enough elevation to
make the jump of course when the t-1000
rises from the explosion in his liquid
metal form that's not an actor cameron
had to rely on cgi that's part of what
makes and still makes this one of the
greatest sci-fi action films of all time
it perfectly represents the transition
from practical effects to cgi and cinema
it's no wonder judgment day took home
the oscar for best visual effects at the
64th annual academy awards
now i don't think it gets more badass
than a cyborg schwarzenegger riding a
harley-davidson fat boy wearing
head-to-toe leather and holding a
sawed-off shotgun but the night is young
my friend so let's not get ahead of
ourselves
the lobby fight the matrix
so
[Music]
and i already almost did it i spoke too
soon because the lobby fight from the
matrix might just be the most badass
sci-fi action scene to ever hit the big
screen i'm sure you're familiar with neo
and trinity and their rebellion against
the intelligent machines that have
created the matrix to distract humans
from their reality i'm sure you're also
familiar with the groundbreaking
bullet-time vfx that's become synonymous
with the matrix franchise but did you
know that the lobby shootout scene was
mostly achieved using practical methods
neo and trinity enter the building
carrying an overwhelming number of
firearms and naturally they're swarmed
by guards what ensues is one of the most
jaw dropping wall flipping guns blazing
debris flying face kicking fights you've
ever seen outside or inside the matrix
one shot in particular features neo
doing a cartwheel over an m16 rifle
picking it up with one hand and then
immediately shooting a group of guards
while still cartwheeling it's insane and
get this just the setup for this shot
took almost a day to reset with the
special effects team having to reload
the roughly 4 thousand squibs in the
walls which means that keanu reeves and
his stuntman chad stahelski were under
immense pressure to pull off these moves
in as few takes as possible the two
practiced cartwheeling with their eyes
closed knowing that they wouldn't be
able to see much of the action once the
explosions went off
[Music]
magically reason stahelski managed to
pull off many of these stunts in one
take but still stachelski sustained
several injuries during the making of
the matrix including broken ribs and a
dislocated shoulder so we don't go
thinking these were just some bendy
spoon-fed actors that we're watching
here again these are badasses once again
wearing head-to-toe leather i'm seeing a
trend here
the outpost 29 battle starship troopers
this place crawls sir we need pickup now
watch your position come down on this
transmission inside the outpost that's
crazy well i hope you have a crazy pilot
okay so the outpost 29 battle from
starship troopers doesn't feature any
head-to-toe weather but it does have an
army of arachnids aka an insectoid alien
race that has evolved to colonize
planets with the use of advanced
technology and anything involving aliens
gets the immediate badass stamp of
approval these are just the rules folks
i don't make them i'm simply a notary
the most repulsive creatures in the
arachnid army are the four-legged
warrior bugs who can camouflage with
their environment and reproduce in much
larger numbers than other arachnids
their role in the army is similar to
that of the orcs that order the rings
they're the grunts of the operation the
ones you send to battle in high numbers
knowing they'll take the initial brunt
of the opposing force and that's exactly
what happens at outpost 29 on planet p
when the federation falls into a trap
gets swarmed by warrior bugs and the
arachnid army finally breaches the
perimeter
let's take a moment to remember that
this film was released in 1997
and somehow the special effects
specifically are warrior bugs still hold
up i'd even go a step further and say
that they're on par with the visual
effects you'd see in big budget films
from the last five years that's because
much like jurassic park starship
troopers use prosthetics miniatures
models and other practical methods in
conjunction with cgi instead of relying
on cgi alone this hybrid method is one
of the main reasons the aliens in this
film make for such menacing antagonists
they were believable but as you can
imagine this wasn't a cheap approach and
starship troopers ended up costing over
105 million dollars to make but it was
nominated for best visual effects at the
70th academy awards and it's safe to say
that the outpost battle had a lot to do
with that
optimus prime vs bonecrusher
transformers
what would a list of badass sci-fi
action scenes be without some serious
bayhem
well i wouldn't know michael bay is one
of the most influential action directors
of all time and even james cameron has
famously admitted to studying and taking
influence from bay's shooting style so
obviously we can't leave him out here
and in the optimus prime versus bone
crusher scene from the first
transformers well that's just peak bay
hem the fate of humanity is at stake
thanks to two races of robots bringing
their war to earth which i guess thank
you like we don't have enough problems
here already i'm paying almost seven
dollars in gas just to get down the road
and not have to worry about a car in
front of me morphing into a giant robot
and destroying everything in sight
sorry i ran it there and i blacked out
oh yeah the world faces total
destruction but optimus prime is
actually a good robot he's part of the
heroic autobots who want to rebuild
their home planet cybertron and end the
war bone crusher on the other hand
well his name is bone crusher he's part
of the villainous decepticons and they
want to utilize earth's machines to
build a giant army again his name is
bone crusher so it's kind of obvious he
might not be a team player prime and
bone crusher face off on a busy freeway
skating through traffic exchanging blows
and eventually tackling each other off
of a bridge prime unsheaths his energy
sword and more or less decapitates bone
crusher who may or may not survive i'm
not giving you a spoiler here go watch
the movie
yes this scene is as epic as it gets but
it almost wasn't to be because michael
bay originally dismissed transformers as
a quote stupid toy movie when he was
approached to direct but once he visited
hasbro he started to understand and
respect the concept and eventually came
around also he wanted to work with
steven spielberg who is an executive
producer because
it's steven spielberg what are you going
to tell the guy no
old painless is waiting predator
come on in
oh painless is waiting
[Music]
the old painless is waiting sequence
from predator could hold the record for
the most ammunition fired with the least
amount of damage done
okay that might not be entirely true
there's some serious damage done to
those tree branches and the other
rainforest vegetation but i don't think
that was the goal the real target was
the jungle hunter aka predator aka the
demon who makes trophies of men and
aliens in this particular sequence
blaine cooper played by jesse the body
ventura is carrying his minigun which he
is dubbed old painless waiting eagerly
for predator or really whoever to appear
so he can blast him to pieces
unfortunately predator strikes first
shooting blaine with his plasma caster
through the chest and killing him on
impact this is when blaine's friend mack
rushes over and begins firing at the
creature slightly wounding it and then
picks up old painless and continues to
blindly fire while the rest of the
soldiers also joining in the fruitless
shootout including arnold
schwarzenegger's character dutch don't
have a lot of luck
we got ventura we got the governator how
many political figures does it take to
kill a jungle creature clearly more than
two predator proved to be an effective
sci-fi horror flick with plenty of
action and one of the most terrifying
and original monsters of any film to
date considering this was screenwriting
brothers jim and john thomas's first
real script and director john
mctiernan's second film ever this was an
impressive achievement especially since
it featured an ensemble cast and shot
entirely on location in various jungles
throughout mexico the old painless
sequence featured tons of fake leaves to
give an extra lush rainforest vibe and
that little bit of green predator goo
was actually from the inside of a glow
stick and this film still received an
oscar nomination for best visual effects
see you don't need all that fancy cgi
just get some glow sticks some leaves
some shredded politicos and you got
yourself a picture get away from her you
beep alien
get away from her you
[Music]
if you thought lieutenant ripley had
already reached peak badass potential in
the first alien then you were sorely
mistaken because the sequel aliens
features ripley at the helm of a power
loader exo suit hand-to-hand fighting a
xenomorph alien queen and delivering one
of the most quotable lines in movie
history get away from her you
well it's a family show but you can fill
in the rest
special effects legend stan winston who
also worked on terminator and predator
had his crew develop a method in which
there would be another person inside the
power loader assisting sigourney weaver
that person was stuntman john leaves the
tandem exo suit was a full-scale prop
made with aluminum fiberglass and pvc
plastic and weighing roughly 600 pounds
please would control the suit from
within while weaver was positioned in
the operator's seat and for some of the
wide shots a skill miniature was built
with puppeteers controlling the
machine's movement and a small doll of
ripley inside
ah
aliens is packed with iconic scenes like
this one and weaver's performance earned
her an oscar nomination for best actress
which was somewhat of a shock
considering that science fiction the
entire genre had been previously
overlooked by the academy though weaver
lost to marley matlin who had won for
the drama children of lesser god aliens
did end up taking home the oscar for
best visual effects i'm seeing a trend
with these movies here one of four
academy awards the late stan winston
would receive in his wonderful career
training complete edge of tomorrow i
found the omega i found it has to be
here turn her a dance germany this has
got to be it it fits the description
perfectly yes she found it again
what difference does it make
cause we're never gonna get there
no matter what we do
no matter how carefully we plan
we can't get off that beach next up is
training complete from edge of tomorrow
lived i repeat directed by doug lyman
the film was adapted from the 2004
japanese light novel all you need is
kill and tell us the story of major
william cage played by tom cruise who is
forced to join a landing operation
against an invading alien race cage gets
thrown into a time loop in which he
relives the same brutal fight over and
over and over again including his death
but with each encore his fighting skills
improved and he and his comrade sergeant
rita of rataski played by emily blunt
come even closer to defeating the alien
okay so we got tom cruise we got emily
blunt and aliens i mean you got my money
already but now you're tossing in time
loops that's a whole new dimension
literally cruz's character cage is
exposed to an alpha's blood alphas are
the commanding unit of the mimic alien
invasion force and this exposure allows
cage to hijack the alien's ability to
reset time so now cage and protaski can
time loop and get sufficient training in
to excel in combat which is how the two
end up at this most climactic moment
frataski assures cage that he can do
this if he keeps showing up she will
train him and that's when cage tells
frataski she already has and boom we're
thrown right into the battle
you can do this
you can
you keep coming here every day and i'll
train you
you already have
[Music]
[Music]
since aliens has us on an exoskeleton
appreciation kick let's take a closer
look at the insane battle suits blunt
and crews are sporting the production
design team handcrafted dozens of these
suits over the course of five months
some weighing anywhere from 85 pounds up
to 130 pounds depending on their
functions
blunt trained for three months for the
role knowing that she'd be performing
most of her own stunts wearing one of
these heavy metal suits which required
the assistance of four people and took
upwards of 30 minutes just to put on
have we mentioned yet that emily blunt
is a total badass
he's a sense offender equilibrium
what's happening we heard gunshots
go
what
[Music]
he's a sense offender is a scene from
the dystopian drama equilibrium in which
christian bale's character john preston
joins the resistance and beats the heck
out of a bunch of armed agents he
clearly doesn't like being called a
sense offender as is evidenced by what
he does to the guard who accuses him of
being such but if you're familiar with
the plot then you'll understand that
being a sense offender is the worst
thing that you can be in this futuristic
totalitarian state the leaders of this
new world blame human emotions as the
cause of world war three so any activity
or object that stimulates human emotion
is strictly forbidden and punishable by
death but clearly we're emotional beings
so the population is forced to take a
daily injection of prosium 2 to suppress
those emotions preston is a high ranking
cleric uncompromising and ambitiously
carrying out his orders to keep the
population under control and emotion
free but after accidentally missing a
dose of prozium he begins to experience
emotional episodes and finds himself
conflicted with his role in society
preston continues to avoid his
medication one thing leads to another
and he eventually aids the revolution in
overthrowing the regime
culminating in this epic action sequence
it was not only clearly inspired by the
matrix but also features some of the
best gun kata you're ever going to see
director kurt wimmer depicts the firearm
as an extension of the user like a sword
to a samurai and the law enforcement
agents in his film are masters of this
fictional martial art which helps them
in enforcing sense crimes but as you can
see in equilibrium bale is basically the
bruce lee of gunkata aka gunfu aka do
not mess with that guy the exosuit
district 9.
keep your positions
[Music]
did you really think we weren't gonna
squeeze in some more exo suit
appreciation before this episode was
over then do you know me at all how
could we not include the exo-suit scene
from the 2009 sci-fi thriller district
9. this time instead of utilizing the
biosuit to fight against
extraterrestrials like in aliens and
edge of tomorrow the protagonist here
wikis vandemir uses the suit to fight
off human mercenaries and rescue an
alien named christopher
yes the alien is named christopher which
is still better than naming your robot
robot director neil blomkamp was already
an established special effects artist
and 3d animator and when peter jackson
saw bomb camps real he was so impressed
that he decided to produce district 9
which was an adaptation of blomkamp's
short alive and jober well blomkamp was
really supposed to direct a film
adaptation of halo with jackson
producing that fell through so they
decided to make district 9 instead the
point is this was actually blomkamp's
first feature-length film which is
pretty astounding considering it was
nominated for four oscars including best
picture and where is it best visual
effects the latter of which should not
be surprising to anybody
[Music]
you can thank the embassy effects
studios based out of vancouver for
rendering this exosuit sequence using
the industry standard software autodesk
and mental ray and additional plug-ins
from sapphire all the aliens in this
film are cgi except the ones that appear
on the operating table in the medical
lab which makes this film even more
impressive considering how expensive
top-notch computer graphics can be and
the film's entire budget was only
30 million dollars and still the alien
is named christopher
gypsy danger vs leatherback pacific rim
and last but certainly not least is
gypsy danger versus leatherback from the
2013 monster film pacific rim directed
by guillermo del toro i am well aware
that a scene featuring a giant monster
fighting a giant exoskeleton doesn't
require any real context and it's just
objectively awesome and as we've already
learned exo suit equals badass so yeah
this scene slaps but for those who were
curious that monster leatherback is part
of a legion known as the kaiju who arose
from the sea and brought with them an
all-consuming thirst for war as a result
mankind was forced to develop massive
robots called gaggers which humans could
pilot via a neural bridge gypsy danger
was one of the oldest jaegers in active
combat considered obsolete but spoiler
alert when all other jaegers had failed
it was gypsy that came to the rescue and
laid the smackdown on leatherback
del toro hired oscar-winning artist from
industrial light and magic to create the
film's visual effects and additionally
featured miniature effect shots provided
by 3210 studios the acclaimed director
took inspiration from the wood block
print the great wave off kanagawa for
the film's ocean battles and for battles
in general like this one he was
influenced by france cisco goya's
painting the colossus and wanted to
evoke the same sense of awe in these
shots as you get from goya's work and
there you have it our selections for the
most badass sci-fi action scene as
always we couldn't include every
sequence that fits the bill but we got
plenty more episodes of rt essentials
coming your way so i'm sure we'll get
there eventually thanks for watching i'm
mark ellis and no this is not an exosuit
[Applause]
[Music]